ça fait longtemps qu'on a pas fait un
casse-tête sur cette chaîne et
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu un casse-tête de
de Constantin c'est quelque chose qui
est pas encore sorti je suis le premier
à l'avoir et apparemment il faut plus
d'un millier de mouvements pour l'ouvrir
c'est extrêmement long c'est extrêmement
dur
donc je vous le dis direct peut-être je
la prends de vidéo c'est possible si je
le fais en vidéo vous aurez très
prochainement la deuxième vidéo
exploration de la boîte déjà je suis
très content et très touché d'être le
premier à la recevoir elle est
extrêmement lourde vous vous rendez pas
compte mais c'est fat là il y a des
lamelles comme ça de partout qui
communique quand je pousse là ça reposer
l'autre côté là il y a des picots alors
et Constantin on sait jamais si ça se
lève ou pas mais je pense pas que ce
soit le principe un petit trou en bas
les pas de vis et là tous les côtés sont
sont identiques c'est-à-dire ils ont ces
quatre petits picots et ça ça peut
bouger donc moi je pense qu'il va
falloir trouver une manière de lever les
quatre côtés de cette boîte en jouant
avec les petites lamelles qui j'imagine
sur interconnecté à l'intérieur
l'exploration rapide fait plaisir les
retours des Castets ah bah tiens lui il
bouge je vérifie pour les autres ok donc
j'en ai un premier il bouge de ce côté
là ça force un peu d'ailleurs et de ce
côté là si je le pousse ici que se
passe-t-il ensuite alors il y a lui qui
peut bouger là d'accord il peut dire lui
qui peut bouger mais que dans un sens ok
parce que oui ouais d'accord ok notre
stratégie ça va être la suivante je vous
le dis de tout pousser les quatre d'un
bord dans la même direction pour pouvoir
lever en fait le petit truc là je
possède lui j'aimerais bien pousser tous
les autres là je réussis à bosser lui
j'aimerais bien pousser tout cela donc
c'est pas forcément tout bouger pour
tout bouger ah ça ça me permet de
libérer lui OK et ensuite je peux
continuer comme ça non ça aurait été
trop facile donc là je suis bloqué là
j'ai fait tous les moves possibles
quoi qu'après je peux repousser lui et
peut-être ça me débloque quelque chose
c'est possible oui ça me débloque ça
d'accord ok il va falloir qu'on trouve
un système comme ça d'aller-retour
j'imagine je poussais comme malade je me
suis bah ça va sortir pas du tout Fabien
je vais continuer à jouer peut-être avec
ces deux-là lui je peux je peux le
rentrer lui d'accord alors celui-ci je
leur rentre est-ce que ça actionne
quelque chose là-bas non bon j'attaque
clairement ce côté là moi dans ma tête
ce qui est peut-être pas du tout la
bonne strat d'ailleurs moi je me dis
qu'ils sont interconnectés dans les
croisements donc lui par exemple il peut
pas être dépendant de lui donc si je
veux pousser cela je pense qu'il faut
que je cherche à bouger quand même cela
il faut tester des combinaisons pour
comprendre un peu mieux ce qui se passe
tu veux essayer de lever quelque chose
avec moi Loïc
un petit chocolat pour Noël ça fait
plaisir ou carrément Harry Potter Harry
Potter
Harry Potter dedans il est
frérot là on voit qu'ils sont sur deux
étages c'est l'âme là sont au-dessus de
ces lames là il faut travailler à se
dire je pose par exemple toutes
celles-ci d'un côté et je vais lever lui
c'est pas un bail de c'est pas un truc
séquentiel c'est ancienne je vais
descendre lui
que
oui
[Musique]
j'ai presque espéré il y a vraiment que
toi ici qui se passe au moins après
quand tu as trouvé la logique ça peut y
aller quoi tu vois
et là je suis bloqué sur ces mouvements
là ce sera vraiment pour l'ouverture
finale ça pour moi c'est vraiment clouté
le soleil il est clouté dedans tu vois
quand il tire dessus est-ce que un peu
comme sur un séquentiel là tu penses que
c'est en terme de séance en couleur en
coupe je le sais puisque Constantin nous
a donné l'info on est les premiers à
l'avoir cette boîte maintenant
exclusivité exclusivité
il y a minimum 1000 coups à faire
minimum on peut faire là cette fois moi
j'ai dû en faire 500 là déjà toute
manière mais après il y a 1000 coups
dans n'importe quel sens en fait puis
mille coups et ça s'ouvre mais long
mais tu penses pas que ce serait
beaucoup plus simple si genre on
enlevait le haut comme ça on pourrait
voir ce qu'on faisait le toujours je
suis allé à
IKEA puis alors par contre waouh un truc
de ouf j'allais vraiment dire Ikea bah
ouais mais comment
action tu aurais pu aller à Gifi tu
aurais pu aller à le magasin
ça n'existe pas et du coup je suis allé
à et donc j'ai trouvé une boîte avec une
clé tu vois je fais ok il y en a encore
pour trois heures je mets la clé la
boîte c'est ouvert mais il faut que
Constantin aille chez Ikea qui découvre
ce système incroyable de en fait ça
s'ouvre ça me fait penser au chocolat et
à Milou et micode aussi MyCode mais il
fait pas de foot non
[Musique]
mais est-ce que tu comprends ce que tu
fais ou tu comprends pas la staton alors
je tâtonne mais par contre je retiens
tout ce que je fais tu retiens tout ce
que tu viens de faire ouais alors qu'on
parlait d'Ikea et de micode ouais
d'accord moi je vais m'oublier le moment
où je suis arrivé ici et toi tu te
souviens de d'accord
[Musique]
vous avez peut-être pas entendu mais il
y a une vraiment la sirène
on rejoue la scène
c'est poli en plus pas ça les Américains
[Musique]
sur cette table vidéo ce serait drôle
mais il y a un petit côté Jérôme les
tutos et puis un petit côté clame aussi
pour le AdSense
une autre config mais j'ai pas envie de
rentrer eux quoi moi je vais faire pipi
je reviens et
moi j'ai fini c'est ça tu te tu te
débrouilles OK
[Musique]
oui Loïc Lagarde j'aurais besoin de
papier et de crayon s'il vous plaît
c'est vos tik tokman
je reconnais c'est faux alors pourquoi
tu as besoin de du papier et du crayon
Fabien pour te rappeler ces séquentiel
Fabien mais si c'était séquentiel on
aimerait monsieur c'est qui a une
séquence à trouver donc c'est un peu
séquentiel en fait je suis arrivé à
plusieurs configs où je me retrouve
bloqué donc je me dis il faut que je me
note quand même ok je sais que pour
sortir lui il faut que je fasse tel
figure tu vois ce que je veux dire tu
veux que je te fasse un carré déjà
est-ce que tu peux dessiner un mouton là
dedans un petit dessin un objet un truc
qui existe dans la vie quotidienne
n'importe quoi tracé j'utilise ça
souvent mentalisme on ne dessine pas
quelque chose de carré dans un carré ah
bah non on dessine un rond
c'est gentil c'est une pomme mais oui
une bombe c'est bien et c'est parce que
c'était clairement par rapport à toi
parce que tu es une bombe bombe
d'intelligence parce que je suis golden
du coup
ça c'est une bombe aussi une pomme
et je suis un pote donc je suis un peu
une pomme pote Virginie on a un test
pour toi tu dessines un objet de la vie
quotidienne ce que tu veux de à
l'intérieur de ça ok ce que tu veux quoi
et voilà
je suis en train de démontrer que dans
un carré tu dessines toujours un cercle
tu vois bah c'est une loupe
et après tu as un casse-tête à on fait
du mentalité sur des feuilles comme ça
je fais des petits trucs psychologiques
essayez chez vous vous faites ça
j'ai du montage
7 j'espère qu'il va pas me parler tout
le trajet
c'est terrible
[Musique]
j'ai pas envie de caster si j'ai envie
mais j'ai pas envie qu'il soit dur
c'est vrai c'est beau ce que tu dis Loïc
donc là comme vous pouvez le constater
après 42 minutes c'est bon j'ai réussi à
le remettre dans son état initial
bon j'ai juste noté comment bouger
celui-ci là comment bouger lui
d'ailleurs ce serait bien que je que je
me note des petites choses non j'ai pas
envie d'altérer le casse-tête il
n'empêche que ces deux-là ont toujours
été fixés j'ai trouvé comment tout
bouger sauf ces deux-là ça c'est un vrai
souci quoi j'aimerais juste essayer de
le commencer autrement si je commence
par là je peux faire ça ok c'est une
autre forme de départ si ça se trouve je
me plante depuis le départ à vouloir
faire mon début dans ce sens là alors
c'est un heureux hasard que j'ai appuyé
là du premier coup donc je vais appuyer
là du premier coup pour voir à partir de
là je peux donc du coup bouger celui-là
si je revêt dans de l'autre côté je peux
pousser celui-là c'est intéressant mais
c'est pas du tout la séquence dont on
avait l'habitude tout à l'heure là du
coup ça ne peut rien changer de ce côté
là par contre c'est censé pouvoir se
changer un truc ici
[Musique]
à revenir entre guillemets ah je sais ok
lui je veux le bouger lui j'ai essayé on
va dire le 01
- 1
une autre feuille s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
oui
1 et 0 la patience la patience
[Musique]
oh [ __ ] donc ça par contre je me le
noter on va pas perdre l'info quand même
ok là on a donc ces quatre de ce côté ce
qui nous libère complètement ce petit
truc là en temps normal
c'est pourquoi il me fait ça lui je
comprends pas parce que pourtant quand
on fait ça on voit que ce qui bloque
c'est c'est les bâtons c'est pas il y a
pas autre chose qui bloque là si j'en
referme
c'est bien le sentiment que c'est le
bout de bois ça c'est vraiment pas cool
quoi est-ce qu'il faut qu'on en est deux
en même temps qui sont si je vais en
avoir deux en même temps j'ai juste à
faire ça peut-être que quand je fais ça
c'est un animal un autre j'ai pas
regardé ça c'est un truc qui forcément
méchant après
bonjour bonjour
ça t'a fait ça explorer des possibilités
et ça on dirait les dessins d'un tueur
en série un peu non
c'est d'ailleurs son petit camion de
guerre avec une j'ai cru libérer la
deuxième ça a pas marché enfin il y a un
truc qui était très frustrant c'est que
là tu as l'impression que ça bute quand
il y a plus rien ça va pas plus haut
quand même et là tu es là
il y a ce truc là aussi après je sais
comment pousser tous les autres et pour
tout ça j'ai bien pris des petites notes
pour savoir comment j'ai fait ne pas
oublier et c'est ce que vous verrez dans
des prochaines vidéos de ce casse-tête
prenez soin de vous abonnez-vous à très
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]